I have four Pixy Stix I thought I could
have a Pixy every time somebody bit me
okay have a sugar rush you suck no
that's rude don't talk to me like that
so what's going on in this game oh yeah
you got the club key
I got a club key I got I got these plugs
I got three but not four and I think the
fourth one is probably in a club key
door
and I got a valve handle which we
discussed but I don't think I can use it
yet so maybe I should be looking for
Club you have used it before but yes yes
and use it again anywho
Shaw so do I need anything else should I
get maybe like one herb you're losing
cravings I'm out of herbs by the way
after this I've continued to get
severely injured yeah I'm on caution and
where am I going
oh and there's like I'm in like Spider
Haven aren't I uh-huh remember Ellie I
was in deep [ __ ] last time so where am I
going here I want to find a club door I
believe you want to go to ladder right
never the same so to my right yeah I
don't know if you should be like taking
guesses right now because I am like I
think I really think that once you walk
through the door all power to my right
is spider zone isn't on it you could be
that's like spider no this should be
this goes up towards me kill those two
dogs I hope they're dead kill them good
I have concerns
I'm steeping tea by the way for those
keeping team steeping we had this
argument for steep tea you see pit yeah
see the remember the dog jump from up
there but I came there but the other way
I'm sorry I'm like panicking all right
let's go a good thing to do when you're
about to back shot was that up plan
no it's not it's graffiti
I just could really use another plant
right now I could use you'll come across
one what you'll come across one in the
hallway with I forgot I forgot I'm in
trouble where am I going right oh go
into a dork go into a door okay I think
this one's broken
no you can go I know no I can't wait we
wanted there last time no yeah we did
the card reader right but I can't get in
but we went in there last time I think
did you know I have never been yes you
have if not I have not been in there oh
[ __ ] okay just go through any door and
reset the lickers they're gonna kill
that Club doors back
I already got hit once I need to take
out these liquors shouldn't I just shoot
them
you can't shotgun them yet I got I got
way more hey no memory of this place
oh god you are so much safer in reman
sir I mean I am NOT doing well
[ __ ] you guy for real looks like a
teenage mutant ninja turtle without a
shell now there's another one how kind
of the way I see it I'd I'd rather not
take another hit just like I'm in
trouble pretty important at this point
where are you sick [ __ ]
gird your loins keep your wits about you
now we don't stay sharp I need to
convince okay where are you where are
you precious she's gonna lick me I just
know it got him oh you almost got too
fast I will look at his little pointy
thing are you talking on his wiener
it's bloody but when he wieners all
right that was a club door up pretty
positive Club door honey his right
honestly I feel way better I just want
him dead so here no that's where you
come from that's where you go back to
the precinct
you want to look at a mitt sure yeah
this is the one mm-hmm this is a big
deal what do you think about me changing
to how do you feel about that pretty
apathetic I'm not feeling much yep push
pristine doors for a resonable game
please don't no no I really I know you
haven't come that far if you die it's
not the big deal it is a big deal to me
these things are all gonna wake up [ __ ]
yeah they are but guess what you got
some good stuff coming up we actually
have a decision to make I think I do we
talked about this briefly which one I
was speaking in general terms there is
something that will make oh okay there
is something that will make this game
easier or the next time I play this game
easier and I encouraged take that yet I
encouraged you to make this game easier
because I'm gonna die
well yeah also I don't that's what I
don't I would shot
gun him at least why he's close shot
kind of like once
or handgun you could probably do a
heaven you have not got that far to try
the handgun to shoot them like searching
him now
yeah no you need to tell me about the
hours
well there's like dudes all over the
place of course they're coming
this music is making everything worse it
does make everything worse yeah you got
your good
get in my camera range [ __ ]
yeah getting good someone's mowing the
lawn except the grass is zombies lawn
mowers a gun stop it stop shooting well
they're lifting their heads well I think
he was dead hey dead people don't do
that that people don't come back to life
and lurch towards you and eat your
brains but they do that same wait check
that left side I think you don't think
there's anything but outside oh the left
part of this that's okay it's just one
big thing all right cool
yeah so now you got the card for that
card reader across the hall right right
right
and now that I've killed the liquors I
don't have to worry about it and I
didn't take one lick of damage except
for one lick of damage that I did take
that liquor that liquor got me oh so
you're gonna pick a stick every time you
get hit up to four because that's all
the amount of pixies yeah I'm getting
that
tarek taste in my mouth just imagine why
you're tasting right now good thing
we're not wasting any time do it well
sugar it up you should make the thing
you're gonna eat when you get hit
disgusting so you don't get hit like
vinegar so we take a tank in the vinegar
there's a really good chance that on
like my third Pixy stick I'm really not
alone in it I love how he holds
different parts of his body depending on
whether he's moving and I like wait I
might stop my hip is Burt wait my my
always holding his side no he's not it's
not moving
it's hip when he doesn't move you're
just moving to make a point like hip
chest
these both things are wrong with them
yeah there's gonna be a lot of arms in
there was just dangling no nice it's a
mage GMO where oh you just okay
ant shotgun ammo I'm more interested in
this red dot on the wall I will take it
did you say shotgun ammo yeah yeah
really excited about that yes I will
anymore hang on all this stuff is great
very very most like the best feeling
stocking up alright so so so so okay
there is a machine Jonny - calm down
slacker
yay okay but I think for the purposes of
this play because we're playing through
all the Resident Evil's or the numbered
ones we're trying to fly through them as
fast as possible this is where it's cool
so you're in Ally on a playthrough right
now if you play Claire on the same safe
I'll be Claire be if you do Clara and
Leon be you essentially take one you can
leave the other item for the second
playthrough the other player but I would
just say take both because we're not
going to play at B scenario so we're
gonna go to resin evil 3 it's true we
are not going to play this game again if
we do it'll be after we go through all
of them yeah which is like something
that future Mary can deal with oh wait
which one like I said
I would say sure take that it takes two
slots uh-huh well I hope I don't need
any take that too
I can't well it's gonna create more
spaces so I'm not don't say for Claire
yeah take it
[ __ ] Claire [ __ ] you Claire my last
playthrough is miss Claire actually I
should probably save it for Claire yay
suck it Claire I check the mat to make
sure you got everything closed lockers
I've missed something yeah I don't know
they're both in the same locker I'll
just do this oh sweet
what about over here and over here okay
I'm out of ideas obviously there's
something else right
why else would it be red eye McCrae well
go green when you leave it or reason to
the police station upstairs club geek
there's a clubs or semi close to you
you'll come across a green herb as well
if I'm not mistaken upstairs I'm left
I'm really glad I killed those liquors
yeah I don't like to look this [ __ ]
anymore you know I don't want you to
Chuck Pixy Stix I don't know how much
you care about press that button I'm
just kidding that's a fire alarm press
that button I pushed it
doors are closed windows closed good
thing huh all right are there zombo's in
here you're gonna go through that like
all right club key could go through the
door immediately to your right then
probably harder do you mean are you have
to sorry okay so I'm taking a right and
going to the precinct is that the
precinct room I don't remember I'm sorry
actually first go to the club door back
by the stairs oh there is a club door
back by the stairs let's drop some Ian
get in into the club please be a safe
room there's one right downstairs with a
[ __ ] ton of stuff for me
what it's a break room that's where
zombies all hang out this is really take
a break looks like all the journalists
and reckons it even write that story
reporter OH
drive room for this can I take it um no
not yet
you can get me any time just from
henceforth it'll be the ribbon room a
nudie girl alright that's great i from
health you're in pretty good shape
thank you cuz ain't gribbins you get two
more oh yeah yeah yeah oh that's a dead
guy hey there boss sodomy oh that camera
is not gonna do you any favors [ __ ] it
just stop his face how I'll he'll still
hurt me just you can chew if you want
you might not be any problem I don't
know Oh another gun you're stocking up
here it's gonna blow us all the way
I finally had the chance to see blue
skies for the first time in ages but it
did little to lift my spirits
I was reprimanded by the chief for
neglecting my duties while I was up in
the clock tower there was only one thing
I still don't understand the chief
seemed to be more concerned about the
fact that I was up on the tower rather
than I was neglecting my duties puzzler
why was the access to the tower
prohibited in the first place hmm
scrapyard Thomas quiet chess okay so
this is really a synopsis you're just
saying like every third word yes but I
feel like it went
that's it has it's a special so as isn't
a word that you would highlight it would
be like special key engraved chess oh my
god doors
wait this is important go back chess
special key a block in graves I already
read it and I read it way quicker than
you by using these okay what do you sort
ins terms so Thomas is the quiet guy who
likes chests so he made a bunch of keys
and he put all the chess piece like
chess symbols on the keys okay made
plans scratching himself was a gross guy
he's really good at chess food he's like
talking about food and he scratched
himself he's sick he literally looked
like The Walking Dead well that's pretty
obvious ooh tasty oh he doesn't feel
good either
yeah you're good there's a bunch of
tubes up there survival pack ready to go
there's all these nudie ladies
everywhere alright so Thomas was the
chess guy okay and so there's an ink
ribbon yeah there's an ink ribbon in
there but I need to go back and get it
wait not necessarily yeah you want me to
take it you're gonna know you're coming
back this way to put the chess plugs and
eventually correct em I'm in it now it's
correct yes let's go all right those
notes neatly let me just clarify me
these guys always take at least one
chunk out of me I'm [ __ ] sick of it
so just doing good and ever thought
about that way so I can go to the part
of the table and try to bait them and
then go to the bottom part of the table
I think it's easier coming from this
part of the room yeah so like bait them
to go up here and then through the
middle and then you go yeah me too once
you get in there
I don't I never see which way to go
that's the problem I have with this game
is that you think that I'm gonna know
what to do and I don't like I could try
to go this way
yeah I made him that way like for a
while keep keep him coming say was long
enough now waiting told you yeah
I would now go nice that might be one
more dude I made you can't kill now your
I hope you're good good yeah that's the
system some [ __ ] in here that some time
yes this way I don't have a lot of time
oh the wait okay we'll be right I'm
calling it
I'm afraid whatever I don't know
doorknobs little llamas I almost want to
go through the doors just like a.j
okay so to the left is there zombo's in
that room this room still red to come to
think of it mm-hmm listen a heck of a
lot of Secrets stuff some on your pillow
for secret eating that's a really weird
deep cut from our home star runner just
stuck in my head and it's been a long
day as usually when we record these
videos sometimes I've had sup you just
kidding
I'm making sure you're alert paint don't
think has anything to do with my
alertness
I'm starting to think you enjoyed this
oh that sounded like a liqueur oh my god
Shaya Safiya sevit um devil no I don't
like chicken Matt it's all the way at
the end so okay the liquor remember he
crashed through the interrogation window
uh window interrogation the one-way
mirror two-way mirror she one way what's
that mean he's in here yeah you're safe
what quit breathing deeply you nad games
but honestly I'm just glad there's not
giant spiders hanging around no no Lord
you check the rest the room first that
looks interesting picture of a man on a
carriage something is on the way yeah do
you remember this light the Queen the
king
and the jack and that carriage will
start running
it's that cog jog your memory at all
we can get to it later no I don't
remember a cog are there cogs in this
game like first or second episode yeah
is this where the president spoke to the
people
it's totally messed up my fellow
Americans
11 12 13
king queen jack son
yes I said like the king queen Jack I
don't know which one's the king and the
Queen and the jack layton cards that
would be twelve and thirteen so this is
no yeah thirteen twelve eleven
well eleven is Jack yes I'd like the
king the Queen then the jack didn't it
oh is that what I said pretty positive
god I'm [ __ ] at this alright let's let's
read it again that makes a lot of sense
I get it now it's a good puzzle Oh Queen
the Queen the King and the jack good
thing we said just backwards a bit weird
okay so it's middle right left yeah
yes
spooch
oh yeah no cool look at the wheel on the
ground I don't know what to do with that
I could lead you back there because I
don't know if you remember at this point
and I kinda wanna as long as I don't die
I really don't want to die for now I
just have backed the main lobby god it's
[ __ ] sounds like there's a liquor in
here you don't like it the mate you mean
like the main main one yeah okay so
you're going press up they go to the
second floor yeah you're coming
one more time
yeah I'll show you so I'm just going in
the main lobby
you take a ladder up run little dude
doorway
I want to live god I want to live
what a funny thing to say wanting to
live seems reasonable does I've been
doing pretty good yeah
only took one nip to the ankles still on
caution all right where am I going
upstairs I don't like going upstairs
kazoo zombies well you have to so that
sucks but you've got a lot of ammo so
you can kill I'm just handgun these
suckers that's what he's equipped to
think yeah did you know I was gonna know
that's weird my fault I really didn't
okay [ __ ] him up he's swinging right now
I know I was gonna hit you might die
actually come on my god whoo this is a
gamble [ __ ] him up oh these [ __ ]
get up what nothing very well might have
killed you if you're on caution if you
did the red attack mm-hmm there was no
no consequence that's what we need is
getting to safe in here you're on that
way I like I like the Oregon kicked in
when the stained-glass showed up it's
very church like isn't there another one
here come to God women are a couple I
think no I think did you kill them maybe
I can't remember it was the other side
that was causing me problems he tried to
escape it like six times
oh yeah that was a bad day yeah okay
here we go
yeah shabanam told you everything I
would put the Magnum away for now
maybe even the machine gun - yeah I got
a machine gun some machine exciting
yeah that's good yeah I feel pretty
confident with these two weapons for now
just like the first game you want to
save a friend you really just want to
[ __ ] something up yeah I feel like sigh
thing I don't remember like any bosses
yet in this game whereas like the first
game I feel like I came across a couple
bosses like a giant snake right now and
those sharks oh my god what all right
where am I going
this is where my memory you are going
through this bottom part that I [ __ ]
this up no I think I'm doing probably
[ __ ] it but you're my only the library
that goes up so I would follow you
blindly you might say go up another
floor [ __ ] I don't know how to go up
another floor [ __ ] I think you did good
we did go the wrong way okay there cuz
that's the helicopter crash this is the
room with the regular the other way it
might be any way you need to do it back
to the library yeah I think if you call
the library no it's a library
erasing time to the library this is
outside with the green herbs that's
where the outside that's where you got
those herbs saved that's the crow
hallway that's the I remember the
outside stairs
that's the stairs to that to that to
that it might be their bottom right or
it might be other side check them both
out if you want me to the library
I remember this there yeah you almost
had to eat a Pixy stick there but you
avoided it I did I feel really good
about it
sorry I already got confused alright so
I'm taking a left and then going
straight I'm going outside yeah sorry
for watching that know exactly where we
should be going but check it out I don't
like walking around yeah exploring up
getting to know the police station
better getting to know zucchini zombies
in the area is the crow hallway just go
straight
oh go go on the stairs and through there
you got herbs here I'd sure did I wish
there was more
yeah this would bring you to so when I
go through here I'm gonna open up my map
and then let's reconsider our options
here no there's just the precinct again
I totally totally should have known the
other bit okay that's fine
fixable totally I don't I love this game
but I enjoy this I'm having a good time
I like you what's happening
so the thing is is you don't understand
the first one I think was even more
convoluted than this one like the
mansion play that one so it's just like
whoops my brain but the more we got lost
the more I learned so it's okay because
every time I make a wrong turn I'm like
oh right when we go outside downstairs
this precinct upstairs is the part with
that statue so all this um oh wait no I
went too far
so yeah it's like all this stuff I agree
like to maybe someone who's like a
die-hard fan you're probably like just
observing all of my failures and that's
that's rude to think of it like that
you seem defensive I'm doing the best I
can I know I'm not good at it first
place
I I would even think most people's first
playthroughs are probably better than
mine but I've never done tank controls
before and these early resident there
might be zoms here no okay some I go up
there and then okay yeah going up in the
library
okay so am I going through these doors
or one more well then it's solved there
you go
up through there no look at my eyes they
got all wide no nope nope nope that's
too many no that's not near you that's
the shutter door how I know when did
that been why just a matter of time
until they come in here so am I going
right to that door yeah that's all I
have
that really sucks that was like we got
some yes ma'am oh you owe me you owe me
a machine get him down
alright so now I think side all right
the other up here yeah so to the right
yes but first is there a zombie in here
is there a goddamn dog in here check it
this way first though am i trying this
way yeah
walking over there
click around I will know all right that
seems misleading wouldn't unnecessary is
such a long hallway all right here we go
don't I don't want to die oh yeah the
cog room yeah okay
so let's like do this I stand corrected
let the record state show yes it's just
like eight zombies don't go down there
yet hold on oh yeah don't go down there
yet go back to the bottom of the stairs
and make sure of something
are you worried you're scaring me
what's down there no press the press
that generator quick see if okay I think
that's
okay what are you doing nothing just
yeah go down so we got the night plug
are you [ __ ] with me or are you
forgetting things and you're just trying
to cover up your tracks I'm gonna let
you might as well
no please don't please don't these are
the designers kill you but you'll shut
them sweet okay what oh you know it I
don't know it this might be a good time
to say this I'm a little worried by you
can go back to the save room if you want
don't snap this no that's where he just
was don't go there yet okay so here yeah
and into here yeah
is there anything in this secret creepy
area run away from the eyeball how is so
creepy so it was like and I've always
had tongue cuz it like licked into death
or something was an eyeball yeah sorry I
and but he died from tongue or like I
was like which one is the save room
that's none of these are save room key
Carter that's the power room where's the
save room here kennel you might need to
go through oh sorry I don't want to go
through the sewers cuz that's where the
spiders are well that's this that's the
kennel sewers you're good on this one
that's right near the save room okay
so straight into the left yeah it also
might be a good time to end this episode
want to keep there because then you got
them well I'm afraid I'm gonna die you
have picked up many health but here you
got a lot done
like I feel like I'm pushing it in terms
of like nothing bad has happened to me
it no no I don't have any save ribbons
is there a safe box because you you
don't have anymore in the save boxes
you're out
I don't know I think I might have one
left I don't know let's just get to the
save room whether you can say or not
we'll end the episode and then like no
yeah we just start the next episode
right after this we're coming up on
about a 45 minute episode but you know
I've done say have a box if there's
there at the save Riven room that we
thought of for is a box
yeah when you got two more in that other
room good shape but that other room is
now there's like six guys in that
hallway right and that's a bummer I
think I'm just gonna shoot him to death
oh yeah you might as well I don't think
I think I'll be able to talk him out of
but unless you need those safe rooms you
don't need to go back up there right now
okay all right no death do you want a
pixie stick nothing victory pixie stick
I'll raise one but I won't finish it you
got it you got some stuff done this
episode do not being it will come back
are we gonna record another one today
all right sweet bubble Knievel every
week on game bot all right I'm gonna
outro because she's a few guys yeah I'm
sure on the next episode we'll see you
next time
hopefully she find some health
you